>>> BEING A NEW CAST MEMBER AT
"SNL," YOU GET A LOT OF ADVICE.
>> ADVICE FROM FRIENDS, FAMILY,
VETERAN CAST MEMBERS, EVEN
LORNE.
LORNE TOLD ME, "DON'T DO TOO
MUCH IN THE FIRST COUPLE SHOWS."
>> LET THE AUDIENCE DISCOVER YOU
AND GET TO KNOW YOU.
>> UNTIL WE FIND WRITERS WHO
UNDERSTAND MY VOICE, MY ODD
HAUNTING VOICE.
>> HE TOLD ME TO JUST BE ME.
TO TRUST MY INSTINCTS FROM
STAND-UP.
AND I KNOW HOW TO HANDLE AN
AUDIENCE.
HE WAS REALLY SWEET ABOUT IT.
>> SEE?
THIS IS ALL KIND OF CRAZY TO
HEAR, BECAUSE ON DAY ONE, LORNE
TOLD ME WHEN HE OFF, AND HE
SAID, "MOLLY, THERE IS ONLY ONE
REASON YOU ARE HERE.
I NEED YOU TO KILL
VLADIMIR PUTIN."
HE ASKED YOU IF HE'S GONE.
HE SAID, "DON'T WORRY, THE
SERIAL NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
SCRATCHED OFF.
HE'LL NEVER TRACE IT BACK TO
US."
I'M LIKE, "US?"
>> I, FOR ONE, HAD SAID, "DON'T
EXPECT TO SEE IN A BUNCH OF
SKETCHES RIGHT AWAY."
>> LORNE SAID TO REALLY TAKE MY
TIME.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE, DON'T EVEN
WRITE A SKETCH UNTIL CHRISTMAS.
>> MY UNCLE SAID, "MAKE SURE TO
GET AN ACCOUNTANT, AND WATCH
HIM, BECAUSE SOMEBODY WILL TAKE
MY MONEY."
>> I TOLD LORNE, "PLEASE DON'T
MAKE ME DO THIS.
I WOULD RATHER BE ON SKETCHES,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I CAME HERE
TO DO."
AND LORNE GOES, "EVERYBODY HAS
DONE SKETCHES, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
WILL FERRELL AND ADAM SANDLER
NEVER DID?
KILL VLADIMIR PUTIN."
I TOLD HIM TO WAIT.
I TOLD MY AGENT ABOUT THIS.
>> DAVID SPADE CALLED AND SAID,
"CONGRATS ON YOUR FIRST UPDATE
FEATURE.
WE'RE BOTH FROM ARIZONA, SO THAT
WAS REALLY COOL."
>> I GOT FLOWERS FROM
KRISTIN WIIG.
I WAS LIKE, "THAT'S INSANE."
I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE SHE KNOWS
WHO I AM.
>> I GET A CALL IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT.
IT'S FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE,
JOHN KERRY.
AND HE SAID, "COME ON, LORNE.
CAN YOU BE HERE IN 10 MINUTES
WITH YOUR BAGS PACKED?"
I'M THINKING, "PACKED WITH
WHAT?"
>> I FEEL LIKE HE WAS PART OF A
LARGER FAMILY, ALL OF A SUDDEN.
I SAW MY PHOTO ON THE SAME WALL
WITH EDDIE MURPHY.
I MEAN, "THAT'S CRAZY."
>> YOU KNOW, I SAW MY PHOTO ON
THAT I WAS RECOGNIZED AND THEY
THOUGHT THAT I WAS KEENAN, BUT
THAT IS OKAY.
>> AND LORNE SAID, WE CAN GET
YOU TO RUSSIA, BUT I CAN'T
GUARANTEE THAT WE WILL GET YOU
OUT.
AND SO, I GET TO LORNE'S AT 4:00
A.M.
IT'S JOHN KERRY, BILL GATES AND,
WEIRDLY, KELLY RIPA.
WE'RE INSIDE.
WE CAN GET YOU TO RUSSIA, BUT WE
CAN'T PROMISE WE CAN GET YOU
OUT.
AND I REALLY WANT TO BE ON
"SNL," SO I'M JUST, LIKE,
NODDING MY HEAD AND SAYING,
"ANYTHING YOU SAY, SIR."
AND KELLY RIPA IS REALLY SWEET.
SHE LIKE, "WHATEVER HAPPENS,
JUST KNOW YOUR FAMILY WILL BE
TAKEN CARE OF."
BUT LIKE, IS KELLY RIPA GOING TO
PAY FOR MY FUNERAL?
>> I'M WORKING ON A SKETCH THIS
WEEK AND LORNE SAID, "DON'T RUSH
INTO IT."
HE SAID, "EVEN IF I'M NOT IN ANY
SKETCHES FOR THE FIRST YEAR OR
TWO, THAT'S FINE."
>> I TOLD LORNE I WAS WORKING ON
A SKETCH FOR ME AND MOLLY, AND
HE JUST, KIND OF, STARED OFF
INTO THE DISTANCE AND SAID, "IF
WE EVER SEE MOLLY AGAIN."
I KNEW THAT AIN'T FEEL RIGHT.
>> I'M THROWN IN BACK OF A VAN.
I HEAR A MILITARY GUY SCREAM,
"IF SHE GETS CAPTURED OVER
THERE, SHE IS ON HER OWN."
AND I WANT HER TO BE LIKE --
IT'S ACTUALLY LIKE -- IT'S
ACTUALLY "THEY," NOT "SHE."
BUT IT DIDN'T SEEM LIKE THE
RIGHT MOMENT FOR THE PRONOUN
TALK.
THEN WE DRIVED STRAIGHT THROUGH
THE NIGHT AT, LIKE, 150 MILES AN
HOUR AND I'M LIKE, "WHOA!"
THE HOURS AT "SNL" IS REALLY ARE
CRAZY.
>> WE WERE TEXTING EACH OTHER
THE FIRST WEEK LIKE, "GOOD
LUCK," "BREAK A LEG," AND THEN
MOLLY TEXTED, "I HAVE TO KILL."
IT'S LIKE, "DON'T PUT THAT KIND
OF PRESSURE ON YOURSELF."
>> YOU REALIZE THERE'S THIS
WHOLE COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE WHO
WORK AT "SNL," AND WE'RE ALL
JUST HERE TO DO COMEDY.
EXCEPT, APPARENTLY, MOLLY.
>> THE VAN SCREECHES TO A HALT.
THEY THROW ME ON TO A DOCK, RIP
OFF THE HOOD.
AND I'M LIKE, "IS THIS THE
PANAMA CANAL?"
THEN A GUY WALKS UP IN A SAFARI
HAT AND A WHITE MUSTACHE.
I SWEAR TO GOD IT WAS LORNE'S
TWIN BROTHER, AND HE SAYS --
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
THEN THEY DRIVE AWAY, AND I GO
TO CALL AN UBER, BUT I CAN'T USE
MY PHONE BECAUSE THEY BURNT MY
BETTER BREAD PHONE.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU'LL
HAVE TO REALIZE YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE GOOD SHOWS AND BAD SHOWS.
LAST WEEK, I GOT ON WEEKEND
UPDATE.
THIS WEEK, I GET TO PLAY
KANYE WEST.
YOU JUST HAVE TO ENJOY THE RIDE.
>> EXACTLY.
DON'T TRY TO WRITE OR PITCH
IDEAS.
DON'T EXPECT ANYONE TO PUT YOU
IN SKETCHES OR GIVE YOU A
COMPUTER OR AN OFFICE OR AN I.D.
SO YOU GET INSIDE THE BUILDING.
YOU JUST GOT TO CHILL AT HOME.
>> AND BE MORE EXCITING THAT
THERE ARE FOUR NEW CAST MEMBERS
SO WE CAN EXPERIENCE IT
TOGETHER.
>> LONG STORY SHORT, MOST OF MY
FIRST WEEK AT "SNL" IS ABOUT
CONNECTING BUSES THROUGH
CENTRAL AMERICA.
BUT I MADE IT RIGHT BEFORE THE
SHOW OPEN, AND JUST BEFORE THE
COLD OPEN STARTED, LORNE CAME UP
TO ME AND SAID, "MOLLY, I'M
REALLY PROUD OF YOU."
AND JUST SO YOU KNOW, WE NEVER
MAKE CAST MEMBERS KILL PEOPLE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS REALLY COOL.
KILL OSAMA BIN LADEN?
NOW I GOT A TASTE FOR IT.